you should be completely fine with your
partner doing only fans or perhaps even
escorting I think if a man is really
comfortable with that that's like a red
flag to me it's an example of men
suppressing their instincts because the
instincts towards jealousy is so strong
if you're putting loads of resources
into raising children that you've had
with this woman you want to know they're
yours make guarding is what the
biologists call it but you have to find
a way of accommodating your instincts
you can't just try and suppress them and
try and like rewrite the human blueprint
I don't see men on the internet saying
you girl should ditch your job and go
and do it the only people online sex
work is real work seems to be women yes
men are the ones that are paying for
their images once they're in the game
but I think that's because once women
cross that threshold and become a
twerker or whatever they're in a
different category right and it's like
oh well they're doing it I didn't get
them into it so I'm just going to
continue to fund them but if you were to
say to most men I think would you advise
that pretty girl to get into only fun so
that you can see her nudes most of them
would say probably not